let's start with crime and policing
minister kit malthouse
good morning uh minister
morning trevor uh the prime minister's
um been in kiev talking to mr zelinski
and about providing more weapons what
has he promised and when can the
ukrainians expect delivery
well obviously we're funneling as much
assistance as we possibly can both
financial and military into ukraine as
quickly as we possibly can
yesterday obviously there were promises
of more equipment 120 armed vehicles
anti-ship missiles and that was on top
of another 100 million of general
equipment
but it's worth bearing in mind we've
also taken measures to assist
economically lifting tariffs on most
imports coming in from
ukraine and also adding another 500
million pound of million dollars sorry
of loan guarantee uh through the world
bank to assist ukraine in its economic
welfare as much as possible and that of
course is on top of us being one of the
biggest bilateral humanitarian donors
into the area we're pulling out all the
stops to try and help ukraine as much as
we possibly can the prime minister being
there on the street quite a remarkable
moment actually that walkabout uh even
for me who's followed the career of the
prime minister over many years as you
know um i think symbolize the support
and the leadership that we're trying to
show across the world as we you know
seek a victory for ukraine
we'll we'll come to the issues of
sanctions and so forth in a moment let's
just stick with the military situation
for the if you wouldn't mind um
this morning we're reading about what
looked like war crimes uh by the
russians what does the latest
intelligence tell us about what's
happening uh on on the ground please
well obviously there are um it's a fast
moving and difficult situation in which
the the kind of fog of war uh is is
makes the situation sometimes unclear as
far as we can see obviously uh ukraine
is resisting strongly uh the russians
are falling back in particular areas but
it did feel yesterday coming through
certainly on on some of the publicly
available information as if russian
forces were massing for an assault uh in
the east of the
country we're watching very carefully
and doing what we can to reinforce the
ukrainian military
as much as possible to resist any
further attempts by russia to take their
country and to push them back where they
possibly can
so so the advice that you're getting uh
or the intelligence you're getting at
forgive me is essentially that if there
is uh if you like a retreat by the
russians it's in order to regroup
and to mount an assault on the east of
the country donbass and luhansk for
example
well trevor i obviously don't want to on
on screen here today uh give a sense of
what we think may happen it may be
happening and therefore may be second
guessed by the the russians as say it's
a horrible situation the ukrainians are
fighting bravely as the prime minister
said like lions we're doing what we can
to reinforce them and give them as much
weaponry as they possibly can including
anti-ship missiles now to defend
themselves um and if possible uh move
the russians off their uh territory this
is turning into a much longer conflict
than i think the russians calculated for
and much of that is down to the
fortitude and the courage of the
ukrainians
assisted we hope uh by the western
munitions that have been pouring into
that country defensive munitions
allowing them to defend their turf
but of course um i understand your point
about not wanting to
reveal uh the west military hand one of
the things that we are be becoming
pretty clearly aware of is that there
are war crimes being committed here
and uh allegedly
by russian
forces um
what exactly are we doing to guarantee
that those people are brought to justice
at some point
well obviously that's a matter for the
international criminal court and as you
will know the deputy prime minister
dominic rabb has been over
uh to the hague i think to talk the
international criminal court about what
support we can give them in the pursuit
of those
who've perpetrated what are quite
obviously war crimes uh during this
dreadful dreadful conflict um the
gathering of evidence during the
conflict obviously needs to be done as
assiduously as it possibly can given
that it's a conflict zone and then
following any um
outcome from the conflict that obviously
needs to be pursuit of those individuals
now while that is ongoing
obviously we can take action
domestically around sanctions that were
able to put on individuals
including competence leading generals
and others uh they're involved in it to
signal ah if you like recognition of
their part in this dreadful dreadful
assault upon a free democratic country
but making sure that the icc is in a
good position to deal with this as soon
as they possibly can is is where we need
to be
we understand that uh the metropolitan
police's war crimes unit is involved
here now uh you were yourself
responsible for the metropolitan police
uh for a while when you were at city
hall in london um
can you tell us what they're actually up
to there
well trevor i can't i'm afraid but they
are uh naturally engaged in gathering as
much evidence as they can to offer
assistance in the future if they
possibly can i mean that's an
operational matter for the police they
are operationally independent of me and
indeed of the government generally but
you can guarantee trevor that as we are
putting as much support into the
conflict as we possibly can to support
ukraine's in their fight we will do the
same to bring those to justice who
perpetrated some truly awful crimes
during this dreadful time
you have talked about the sanctions
we've imposed against mr putin's
oligarch friends we have stopped imports
we've thrown russian banks some russian
banks out of the international banking
messaging system swift
to be honest though it doesn't seem to
have
deterred him at all does it
well we shall see trevor as you know um
these sanctions
his troops are still there
yeah his troops are still there you are
quite right uh but as we seek to tighten
the sanctions net as we seek to
coordinate with our international
partners particularly in europe uh to
restrict the flow of money if you like
into russia particularly from their
gas and oil
then that that ratchet if you like
starts to bite much more often uh
sanctions take a little bit of time to
feed through the financial system
but where we can find
uh gaps in if you like in our armory of
sanctions we are closing them as quickly
as we can as you know we legislated very
quickly to give ourselves the agility to
move to try and shut down as much of the
russian economy as we possibly can and
we'll continue to do that in the uh days
and weeks to come you know these uh
sanctions i think will start to bite if
they're not biting already very
significantly in russia and we hope that
that will give mr putin cause to reflect
well we i understand the point you're
making that we're trying to essentially
put a squeeze on the russian population
by
uh preventing imports and so on but the
truth of the matter is
that mr putin's demonstrated he doesn't
care that much if his own people suffer
and as long as the germans continue to
buy his gas as long as the chinese
continue to trade and consume
consumer
goods and as long as india continues to
buy oil and
weapons from
uh russia
he's not that bothered shouldn't we
be focusing more frankly on our friends
than on some some of the things that
we're doing
look we're in constant conversation
treasure with all trevor with all our
allies across the world about what more
we can do
to build a really solid uh barricade if
you like against russian economic
activity across the world just to say we
have no dispute with the russian people
uh this is a dispute with the russian
government led by mr putin who have
ordered this dreadful assault that's why
we've taken measures against these known
associates whether they be oligarchs or
others why we've taken measures against
uh members of the government who
strangely forgive me for entering
forgive me for interrupting you but i
was really asking about our friends here
and we've heard actually from other
members of nato polls for example
and ukrainians themselves that they're
pretty disappointed with what the
germans are not doing do you think any
of our supposed allies and possible
friends are effectively letting down
this effort uh and putting a hole in the
barricade you just mentioned
well trevor look as i said we're
constantly talking to our friends uh in
germany and in france and elsewhere in
europe and in fact the president of
europe of the european commission as you
know visited uh kiev not very long ago
to express her support and the european
union has taken significant measures
having said that you know we do need to
bear in mind that uh you know
certain parts of europe are very
dependent on russian gas they are taking
steps now to wean themselves off the
germans in particular are looking at
what more they can do to bolster their
own defense and of course nordstrom to
that pipeline which was due to come on
stream has been uh shut down or
cancelled
we are pushing as much as we possibly
can for as strong a set of sanctions
from the eu and the wider world as we
possibly can get we recognize that this
is a ratchet we need to turn as tightly
as we possibly can in the cause of
freedom in ukraine and we will support
the ukrainian president as he repeats
those calls across the world all right
before before we come back to domestic
politics what i do want to talk to you
about um
do you feel a bit ashamed that our
neighbors the
irish
reckon that they will welcome as many as
40 000
ukrainian refugees by the end of this
month while we have managed to admit 12
000
of the uh 70 or 80 000 who would like to
come here
well trevor you're right we've had about
just shy of 80 000 applications for
visas of those we've issued uh just over
forty thousand and of that forty
thousand you're right 000 have come to
the uk now though the the difference
between the 40 000 and 12 um might be
for a variety of reasons we know that
yeah but
it's three times for three
has a times
a fraction of ours come on
yeah no i completely understand and i
know that people are
disappointed uh with the progress of the
of the visa regime the home secretary
was out this week expressing her
frustration and regret that it hasn't
been quicker but we are motoring now now
it's worth saying that while we issue
visas to those individuals there are a
lot of people who are um in region in
poland and other countries who are in
receipt of uk visas
but thinking about their options preying
upon
hope upon hope that they can return to
their country but in possession of the
ability to come to the uk for safe haven
if they wish now we are processing as
fast as we can we've now got hundreds of
people from across whitehall working on
this i think we did a thousand yesterday
we will accelerate during the week and
we hope to get out as fast as we
possibly can all right well i no doubt
my colleagues uh next time on this
program we'll we'll check up on that
let's come back to the cost of living
here um
you didn't back off on the national
insurance rise uh don't need to explain
that again uh you published an energy
strategy this week with a lot of
promises about uh wind power and all the
rest of it for the medium term um but i
wonder if you could explain what any of
that is going to do for families who are
going to be faced with a big rise uh in
the autumn when the uh
cap goes
rises
in the context of which
let's remember a quarter of british
families have no savings a third have
less than 100 pounds available to them
uh at at any one time how are those
people going to meet
that demand for a rise in the cost of
energy
so trevor look we obviously
we recognize that the rise in the cost
of living and indeed fuel in particular
is very tough some of that comes from
the choices that we've made about
supporting ukraine some of it from a
post-pandemic kind of boom if you like
it or difficulty in in supply
we're doing what we can to try and
assist in that awful equation for so
many people by targeting as much
assistance as we can particularly those
who are on a lower income or low paid so
whether that's the warm home discount
going to three million people you know
the nine billion pounds uh energy uh
rebate scheme that we put in place
there's lots of support going in there
and in particular worth noting that we
doubled the household support fund now
to a billion pounds targeted at those
who will be really struggling and can go
to their local authority uh for
assistance it's worth it just on your on
your first question though
i did i did let you
advance ukraine as an example but
honestly
you put up the national insurance you
have not uprated benefits uh by more
than what 3.1 percent i think it is now
against an inflation uh rate now about
7.7
these are choices you are making
you are quite right these are choices
that we're making and we have to own so
we took a decision that the backlog in
the nhs required an investment of 39
billion pounds and that's what that
national insurance rise will raise but
remember trevor that the chancellor then
took the step of raising the threshold
which will come into effect later this
year meaning that 30 odd million people
will pay less national insurance as a
result don't forget also there is a if
you like a suite of tools that will
assist people who are low paid so the
national living wage
rose i think last friday by 6.6
we've also um increased the
taper on universal credit meaning that
those in work and in receipt of
universal credit will be better off by a
thousand pounds a year so when you look
at the overall package we are stretching
the financial envelope as much as we
possibly can to try and do two things
first of all to invest in those public
services particularly the national
health service but secondly assist those
people who are really struggling with
the cost of living as much as we can now
these are difficult choices all right
against the backdrop of a balance sheet
with a lot of borrowing on it coming out
of the pandemic and i understand that it
will be very very tough for lots of
people all right let's let's talk about
your principal decision maker on these
questions the chancellor um
i wonder if he's listening to the many
people in this country who are furious
that uh at the revelation
that um he's raising taxes
while his wife made a choice
to pay tax not to the country that uh
her husband's asked to make these
sacrifices not to the country that puts
a roof over her head but to india now i
know it's it's legal and all that you
don't need to explain that to me but
politically just a terrible mistake
massive tenure here
well first of all it's worth pointing
out that
um as mizmerti said she paid uk tax on
all her uk income uh but you will have
seen her statement she accepted that um
there was a sense of disquiet about the
situation and she's moved to
uh correct it now she is a non-competent
in the political fray
but i think both she and rishi have
recognized that that situation was not
one that that was favorable and it was
distracting from the overall message um
you know he's put a huge amount of
effort time commitment and energy into
helping this country get through the
last couple of years um and it's
unfortunate that his wife has been drawn
into this political fray in this way
they've now corrected that situation um
hopefully we can move on well uh we
can't quite move on because uh it's not
just her it's him uh we now discover uh
courtesy of my colleague here sam coats
that um for the first 18 months
as chancellor he held a green card which
you will know means legal permanent
resident of the united states uh
essentially
you know this also that uh that means
the united states expects uh him to pay
taxes on whatever he earned
in the whole world to them first now
not good is it i mean this is really
uh in the time when we want the whole
country to trust government and support
what it's trying to do
it's pretty
it's not a good look is it
well look rishi tsunak was obviously
somebody who it's careless at least well
got himself a place uh overseas at
stanford got a job there and required a
green card as a result my understanding
years ago
yeah but my understanding was trevor
that this was a hangover from that time
and that very often uh people with green
cards who don't go to the united states
don't take advantage of it it just
lapses and gets removed now you know he
obviously yeah but he's not come on come
on minister he's not just anybody he's
the chancellor of the united kingdom
i
i mean i understand understand the
intricacies of the
of the green card system but as far as i
could see and as far as i understand it
actually added more complexity and more
onerous obligations to him not less and
it certainly didn't impact on his tax
position in the uk where he was paying
tax uh but look he may be worth you in
the future getting him on to talk about
that stuff as far as i could see he took
advice from the american
officials he handed his green card back
when he was there and regularized that
position as well
politically
he's toast isn't he
no i don't believe he is he yeah rishi
sunak is has been a remarkable force for
good in this country over the last two
years he put in place some incredible
support schemes during the pandemic
addicts enormous speed you know he
managed to produce a budget within just
weeks of becoming chesler he is a smart
clever committed politician
who has you came into parliament with me
and i've been deeply impressed by him
ever since
uh mr mulhouse i'm i'm sure that uh mr
sunny will be glad to hear your reply as
he consumes his own toast rather than
being it thank you so much for your time
i'm a big fan thanks trevor